gymnasts they are some of the world's
greatest athletes and we have some here
locally who are getting ready to compete
on an international level for a
championship later this month that's
right well rocky theas is live with the
biggest acrobatics program
in nevada to show us what it takes to go
for the gold hey
hey you guys yeah we are just hanging
out here at agc
so ross we're going to go ahead and show
them how it's kind of done
all right all right are you stunning
when children give me a hand okay okay
and then oh got it you got it and then
stand up okay
you got it you got it all right and
we're here there we go so what move is
this this is standing on shoulders
pretty simple
but pretty scary at your height all
right i'm gonna jump down and grab my
hands
so we can show you the real pros
there we go there we go all right now
that i'm done with my career
let's talk about the ones who whose
career has been going for years and they
finally made it
to the world championships they did it's
going to be this month
in geneva in switzerland and vlad on top
and davis on the bottom will be
competing in the 11 to 16
men's pair category at the world age
group championships for acrobatic
gymnastics that is incredible and
they've been training for how long to
get to this moment oh they've been
training for about three years and it's
the first time
here at agc las vegas we've been able to
send a partnership to the world
championships so it's a huge
achievement for them and for us it's
incredible wow i look at these outfits i
love
so what does it take to become an
acrobatic gymnast
well it takes it takes a lot from the
acrobats and not just from the acrobats
the coach as well here we see
tanya tashev head coach and owner of agc
las vegas so
it's so many hours and uh of spotting of
of perfecting the routines perfecting
the move so much strength and
flexibility needed as you can see there
from the acrobats and hours of you know
dedication from the coaches as well
absolutely and i want to point out vlad
our little one right here his mom
it's in his jeans right it is his mom is
a co-chair coach marina and she was
a world champion she's over there
coaching she was a world champion for
um uh in 1993 for russia so
it's in his blood you know he's uh he's
born to it all right well we are going
to be cheering these guys on
look at them wow so what's the website
where people can go if they're watching
this and inspired
and want to get into it agclusvegas.com
people can sign up they can come along
for a try out
uh we're here to take anyone on kids of
all ages and even adults
there we go round of applause everybody
guys you guys are amazing wish you the
best of luck
i will send it back to you weren't they
fantastic
wow we wish them the best i could watch
that for hours
of course they can't do it for hours but
that is so fun
in three years so if we take the class
in three years we're going to be able to
do it i might be able to do a cartwheel
but that's even doubtful